almost ready to
go I call to order the October no it
isn't let's start again I called to
order the Friday November 17th meeting
of Health and Human Services oversight
committee uh the clerk will you please
call the role representative Pearson
here representative King here
representative gray representative
Murphy here representative McDonald
here and by the way I think I made a
mistake that should have been Senator
Gray he's not here sorry about that I
representative
Weber representative
Edwards representative Merchant
yeah Senator
rosenal Senator
avard uh we have six accounted for and
the others um were gracious and let me
know ahead of time that they would be
absent next order of business is the
minutes of Friday October
27th and we will sent these ahead of
time and we have
a hard copy in front of us I move the
minute to be accepted as written
second any further
discussion hearing none the minutes SS
all in favor I opposed minuts are
accepted next item uh before I forget we
are having a December meeting and and
what we do when there is a holiday at
the end of the month we move as we're
doing today the meeting up to the third
Friday at 1:00 so the next meeting will
be December 15th a Friday uh we is it
really I'm sorry I'm never
mind December 15th is a Friday uh it
will mostly be the par minahan going
away way party that I hope will be
extensively catered uh but we may do
some other business too is it going to
be an open bar for
that is Steve Steve
uh here to answer for that can we find
out get back to
us one o'clock yeah when it's on the
third Friday it's usually 1 o'clock
because of a conflict some have in the
morning
DHHS Commissioners up date and the chair
recognizes commissioner Lori
Weaver good
afternoon that was fast it usually takes
a little longer to get through the
meeting minutes I was thought I had more
time thank you for for having me I have
a little bit of a um I guess a variety
of updates for you today uh focusing on
some things that maybe we haven't talked
about in a little a little while and one
of those would be uh retention or uh
vacancy rates so I think I believe might
have been beginning of this calendar
year or maybe a year ago um I sat before
you and talked about some of the
challenges we had with with recruiting
um we I am proud to let you know that we
actually are uh improving our vacancy
rate about a year ago was about
19.6% and we're down to about
17.2% so you know that's you know
roughly we have about roughly about 2700
positions filled a little less than that
when we were at about 2500 so we'll
always have constant attrition
especially with some of our Direct Care
Services but we're making uh gains in
the right direction so we've gotten some
new recruitment tools uh software tools
working with the division of personnel
having um really innovative ways to get
out and get the word out what type of
jobs we have um and what people would be
eligible for so we're going to keep
marching in that direction um it's part
of our road map for the Department we'll
continue um into next year and Beyond of
having Workforce be a priority and be a
goal so so that's good
news and the other SC of good news is
that I recently um nominated Marissa hen
to be Deputy Commissioner of the
department and it was confirmed by the
council about three or four weeks ago so
Marissa hen who was an associate
commissioner is now the Deputy
Commissioner of the department and it's
great to have a deputy I haven't had one
for a year so um happy about that and we
will be we are actively recruiting to
backfill for that associate commissioner
position so at that point I'll hopefully
have a full Senior Team to start the new
year and lastly I just wanted to update
you we talk a lot about all of the
things that are happening um and there's
a lot in the department as we know every
single day there's something happening
but there's actually some construction
happening on our campus and it's been um
on time and is is coming along if you
happen to work at New Hampshire hospital
you are constantly reminded by the
drills and the pounding that there is a
forensic hospital going up right next to
the hospital so that has been steady uh
steady build and they're on time as of
as of this point in time knock on wood
um so that when is the expected opening
date or hope I believe it's the summer
of
25 and then in addition we have also
been doing some Renovations on what we
call our enf unit within the hospital
which is the 35 beds that have been
offline for various reasons over the
last couple of years and that cons
renovation will be complete probably
towards the end of January and we'll
start to bring those beds back online
which will hopefully have an impact at
least for a point in time on our Ed
boarding weight list so um we've been uh
actively recruiting nurses uh we still
have the majority of nurses at New
Hampshire hospital hital are still
agency n nurses but we are hiring
full-time nurses as well so we're making
gains in that direction um as well so I
think I promis to only bring good news
today and that is my good news
list any
questions on the good news list
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and thank you commissioner we for
being here in regards to the retention
or the vacancy rate rather is there
certain sub ET that's more problematic
than others sure yeah really it's our
Direct Care positions it's our font
facing you know whether it's casework or
whether it's actually doing Direct Care
in one of our 247 facilities those tend
to be the hardest to fill thank
you anyone
else thank you so much for your report
thank
you next item is update on protocol for
complaints and
investigations with the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine the chair recognizes
attorney Douglas user
hooot I'll do it in Dutch and okay here
comes one Jessica calipolis
Greek it is Greek that was that was very
close padus it's calopus but that was LE
a long okay got it I was debating
between coin Greek and classical Greek
and I lost thank you for coming well our
our name was changed when my
great-grandfather came to Ellis Island
he was speaking Greek and that's what
they wrote down so that became our last
name and that's how he was very blessed
that it just didn't become
c yeah anyway
yeah okay um so good afternoon um I
appreciate the time um I did send um
a um a handout I don't know if everyone
has it I just want to make sure
no it was sent electronically but I do
have hard copies as
well what's going
on so I'll wait till everyone has it to
go into detail but um this doesn't
include every detail in the complaint
process but I think it's a good sort of
overview and a good place to kind of
start the
discussion oh I have more
here all right so what you have before
you is basically a flowchart
illustrating the post HB 655 and HP 409
enforcement process not only for Board
of Medicine but other boards as well um
and this is for non-emergency
matters so a complaint if alleges
something that would be an emergency
there's a different process we can talk
about if you're you'd like to but this
is a non-emergency
process so a complaint is received um by
the division of enforcement at
oplc and it is reviewed for it's a legal
review um to determine is it facially
valid essentially assuming all
allegations are true does it allege
anything that would be misconduct um or
unprofessional conduct
so we review that if the determination
is that it does not meet that standard
then we draft a recom a recommendation
for dismissal and that goes to the
board so only the board can dismiss
complaints we can only make a
recommendation um we being enforcement
so right now all the attorneys and
enforcement review complaints we take
turns we are hiring an individual to
specific do that attorneys of
enforcement at oplc correct thank
you um so again we can only make a
recommendation we can't actually dismiss
anything in enforcement it's up to the
board so we send the recommend
recommendations for dismissal to the
board and they can
dismiss or they can look at it and say
no enforcement we don't agree with you
and they can send it back to us if that
happens we'll request a response if we
look at a complaint and say yes this is
is facially valid then we would request
a response so those are the two ways
that we get to the response phase once a
response from the lcy is received the
complaint and response are R reviewed
again sometimes the response provides
enough information particularly in um
like medicine cases where they might
provide some documentation some records
to help support their position that
might be enough we may recommend
dismissal again at that point we're able
to do that so that is not depicted here
just because there'd be too many arrows
it would get really messy and confusing
but we do another review at that stage
to determine should it be dismissed or
should it be
investigated so again we would send the
right any recommendations for dismissal
to the board that's purely their
decision they can either agree and
dismiss or send it back to us and say we
don't agree with you enforcement go
forth and
investigate um so if the board sends it
back or we review and say yes this needs
to be investigated it is immediately
assigned to an investig vator who begins
an
investigation uh once they complete
their investigation they draft an Roi or
report of investigation and that is sent
to the board with a recommendation the
recommendation may be to dismiss at that
point or it may be um for adjudication
again that's a recommendation the board
gets the ROI and they make a decision
they can accept whatever the
recommendation is or they can make a
different determination um but the board
at that point upon receiving the ROI
would either dismiss the case or order
adjudication and a hearing would be
scheduled any questions on the diagram
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the question on the
process where you saw the complaint
review what I think I heard was that's
done by attorneys not done by peers so
therefore I don't know whether the
attorney has the clinical knowledge
to make a determination from whether
it's clinically relevant ver it just
legally relevant so how does the
clinical team get pulled into that
review process yes thank you for the
question um so it depends on what the
complaint is right if it says my doctor
sexually assaulted me you don't need a
clinician to tell you that that's
facially valid and needs to be
investigated um if you get a complaint
like this is a real complaint from Board
of Nursing the nurse gave me the wrong
color Jello you don't need to be a
clinician to know that that's the uh
that's not facially valid for the ones
that you do need that expertise um we
would Rely Upon Our contractor um who we
work with who is a physician to help us
make that determination because we're
not doctors um so it depends on what the
complaint alleges sometimes we can tell
from what it says and if we can't if it
has medical language and you know it
talks about standard of care I'm not
going to know that I'm not a doctor so
we're going to rely upon someone who is
to assist us in making that
recommendation or deter mining that it
should move
forward representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman I do how
many complaints you have pending right
now that is a really great question for
Board of Medicine specifically or all
boards well all boards affected by
this um so this is the process I'm
not it's a I don't have a specific
number um we have had a number of
challenges regarding the electronic
system that we keep track of cases in
and a lot of improvements have been made
recently that allows us to better track
them and close out the ones that need to
be um and we are working on getting a
new system that will allow me to just
provide that information but right now I
don't have a lot of confidence in the
data and so I'd be hesitant to give you
a number um what I can tell you is that
through this new process um recently
there was a month where the Board of
Medicine was able to dismiss over a 100
cases because we've made a push um Board
of Medicine does have a lot of pending
cases so we've made a push to review as
many as we can um and to be completely
transparent a lot of those were sort of
in grouped in the same bucket so it was
easy to make a recommendation for a
group of them but we were able to to do
that for over a 100 complaints in one
month which means that those are and
they
and they dismiss them um so that means
that those are taken off the case list
and we can focus on the ones that do
need to be
investigated follow up follow up um when
you say dismissed does that mean
unfounded
basically right it's of evidence
whatever right it it doesn't rise to the
level um it doesn't it doesn't right the
board decided to dismiss it I think our
recommendation would be it's facially
invalid um it doesn't rise to the level
of professional miscon conduct and I
assume they agreed with that because
they dismissed it but they did dismiss
it I have one more one more thank you Mr
chairman what's the and I know it would
vary by department and severity and so
forth but what's the average turnaround
time on on a complaint in the
investigation and so forth
resolution so it does vary a lot
depending on board um also complexity of
complaint um some medicine cases
especially if there's multiple doctors
involved may take much longer
um if it's something that maybe is not
emergent but
is urgent let's say you know it's going
to be prioritized so that would be moved
much more quickly um so it depends I can
tell you what what our goal is moving
forward as we're we're catching sort of
cleaning this up and like I said trying
to clean out the cases that should be
dismissed in investigating the ones that
weren't investigation um the goal is any
complaint the maximum amount of time
from time of complaint receipt to
assuming it goes to adjudication because
not all do but assuming it does to
decision is a year or less most of them
should probably be much less a lot of
them will be dismissed at the complaint
or um complaint response phase some of
them um the investigation may take
longer or shorter um if there's a
hearing obviously that that time frame
is a little bit longer than if the board
dismisses after an Roi but the goal is
every complaint that comes the maximum
amount of time it would be around is one
year and that's assuming that it does go
to hearing okay um there would be a rare
exception for certain cases either
really really complex which we usually
don't see in administrative law but we
can um or if there's a criminal
component sometimes just because the
criminal portion of you know the the
criminal courts might take longer um so
sometimes depending on how we need to
handle things it might take a little bit
longer for our case depending on what's
happening in the criminal court thank
you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for this um flowchart is actually
very helpful for me
um so according to the flowchart unless
you have a need to have a clinician
present or to evaluate the Board of
Medicine will not see this until an Roi
is made is that
correct uh right if we don't recommend
dismiss so then yes first time they'll
see it that is the first time they'll
see it so at the very beginning the
complaint is received I'm assuming that
means also like a um um a malpractice
lawsuit is that correct yes and how does
that report come to you that complaint
come to you does it come with five
bounds of charts from hospital or does
it come with an executive summary how do
you get that report say specifically of
a malpractice suit uh the malpractice
suit typically comes from the court
because they're supposed to know notify
us anytime when is filed um there's a
cover letter saying we're disclosing
this to you and then it's a copy of the
complaint filed in civil court and
that's typically it just one more
followup followup and you mentioned the
complaint reviewed by a contractor is
this some who is what is a contractor is
it employed by oplc or is it do you pull
people in regularly depending on the
case or what is a contractor and where
do they come from sure so we contract
with a physician um who he's an investig
Ator who works with our office um we
have a number of contract investigators
with different expertise so Board of
Medicine currently has one and we're
working on additional contracts for
additional people with different
different areas of expertise um the
Board of Nursing Psychiatry the vet
veterinarians a number of other boards
utilize contract investigators um to
help us where we need that expertise
because our investigators are experts in
investigating but not necessarily in
matter right subject matter um in
medicine or nursing or those types of
things so um so we work in conjunction
with them so when I referred to the
contractor it's the physician that we
currently contract with um like I said
we're working on getting other contracts
into place um we used to have the
medical revieww subcommittee and there
were some challenges with that but when
we lost that um group we did recognize
that we needed additional contracts in
order to con continue this work I'm
sorry just one more f one more um when
we were looking earlier in the year at
the Board of Medicine in the in the
committee or commission or committee to
uh evaluate the Board of Medicine one of
the big issues that came up was Staffing
or the lack of it do you feel like oplc
has staffed adequately enough to handle
the number of cases that come before you
currently I do we did just add I think
it's one and one and a half
investigators we had one part-time
investigator who left and we replaced
that person's position with a full-time
and then we hired an additional
investigator um so right now I feel we
are fully staffed um to handle what what
matters we have and like I said that
goal is to have that one year or less
time frame and as we move along and get
better data we'll be able to identify
whether we truly are fully staffed
rather than feeling like we're fully
staffed so thank you
y representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair thank you for thinking the
question I I Al like C of Murphy said I
found this to be very interesting I
think one of the comments I heard about
this it does not only apply to the Board
of Medicine but to other entities within
oplc so in saying that is the process
going to be the same for other health
care providers whether it be a
podiatrist chiropractor a dentist and so
forth yes um HB 655 and HB
409 essentially Consolidated the process
into one process whereas before we had
50 some OD processes because every board
wanted things slightly different um so
now we have one
process follow up thank you can you
speak to the communication process
between the time a complaint is
filed to the time there's resolution to
it how is the person who's been the
individual who filed the complaint how
are they kept in the loop that
something's actually happening
if it goes out for a year and there's no
communication with the person who's
filed the complaint it's going to sound
like it may be fallowing unde years
that's one of the questions the other
question is going to be is how do the
person who wants to file a complaint
where do they go and how do they know
where to go to file the complaint
because if the system is problematic so
it's two questions I guess one is what's
the communication process with the
person making the complaint what's
communication to the people out in the
public that they where to go to file a
complaint sure um I'll answer the second
one first if that's okay cuz I think
it's a easier shorter answer um so uh we
have a complaint I mean people can file
complaints however they're comfortable
so if some we get some by snail mail
with hard copy sometimes they just email
us we do have the information on our
website how to file a complaint we have
an online form that they can complete
and send to us not everyone's
comfortable doing that so like I said if
they want to email us or if they some
people write out or handw write us
something and drop it in the mail we'll
take it through all those means um when
we get a complaint they get a receipt of
acknowledgement so we have received your
complaint um if it does go to I mean if
it's recommended for dismissal and it's
dismissed early on they're going to get
a letter um from the board indicating
your complaint was dismissed um if it
goes into investigation then an
investigator would reach out because
that's part of the investigation you
don't just take obviously what's in the
complaint you want to talk to the
complaintant and get some additional
information they may have to be a
witness in the hearing so we want to
talk to them um so they would know the
investigator who's working on their
complaint and they would know it is in
process um so they'd have a
a Avenue to communicate with our office
regarding the the status if it's an
investigation um now what we can tell
them is very limited because even though
they are the complainant um
investigations are confidential so they
know it's been filed they know it's
being investigated because they're part
of the process but we're very limited in
what we can tell them um until there's
outcome representative
Weber thank you for taking my question
thank you for being here today and thank
you for the updates um I notice that if
I go to the Board of Medicine page I
can't find the complaint procedure
unless I happen to click on frequently
asked questions and I wonder if it might
be helpful for the public to have a link
on that front page if I go for example
to the Attorney General's office and I
have a complaint about something there's
something right on their front page that
tells me how to get there so I wonder if
that might be helpful going forward okay
I appreciate that feedback um it should
say report or file a complaint at the
top of the page and I thought that there
was a link further down the page but I
appreciate that feedback and I'll
certainly look into it and I'll I'll
bring that back no I'm I'm wrong there
is a there is
a I am mistaken there is a file and
complaint thing it's in the line with
the other stuff so I was reading down
okay still valuable feedback though
because if you weren't able to find it
when you went there looking for it
others may not as well so thank
you my old and big type is really
helpful representative McDonald uh thank
you Mr chairman I used to be an
investigator with um the department and
the Fraud Unit the welfare fraud unit
that's why I I find this very
interesting
uh and I know on an ongoing
investigation you're very limited in
terms of what you can share in fact we
couldn't share anything we take the
complaint and then would proceed and
unless it went to court we couldn't
share anything if it was an
administrative hearing we couldn't share
anything how much are you able to share
when you said you can share the outcome
are you able to share the outcome um um
enforcement is not the board is because
that's a board decision so that's
communicated through the board
administrator um so that is communicated
to both the complainant and if it um you
know if there's if it goes to
investigation then obviously the leny
needs to be notified as well if the
outcome um but it doesn't have to go to
court for the outcome to be known it
does not have to go to court right the
hearing is before the board um and then
the public or yes the the hearings are
public um there I think we've had very
rare occasion where maybe the subject
matter being covered was very sensitive
so it's been sealed or
um portions of it have been sealed but
they are generally public yes okay thank
you you will recall a while ago the
Boston Globe
investigated the matters of a surgeon at
CMC and that the Massachusetts Board of
Medicine reported
20 um settlements and the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine reported none and that
led to borrow multiple pages of uh
report in the Boston Globe I was ex uh
interviewed extensively by the globe I
was in media so you know um and then by
other media outlets and lately they've
been giving me a call and saying how's
it going now compared and I wanted to
wait until I heard from you folks before
I get back to them um and would now the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine have
this
information on report this information
whereas before they
didn't I'm sorry I'm not certain I
understand your question the public did
not know yeah by the New Hampshire
board's Revelations about the uh 20
malpractice settlements of the
surgeon unless they read the
Massachusetts board of medicine's
website and we were told at the time
well the procedures the Staffing the
this it sounded plausible I didn't think
anyone was being bad I just thought we
need to be updated we need to change
procedures we need to hire a few folks
would you say that the legislation now
law and the efforts at
oplc have improved to the point where
that problem will no longer happen
so I think with the improvements that
we've had I mean so if a case like I
said cases are confidential basically
until there there's a hearing right so
the hearings are public so that would be
available that would be noticed that
would that would be public um any
outcome um you know if there's a
settlement agreement if they settle
prior to a hearing but you know
adjudication has been ordered and they
settle or even if it's before then if
there's a settlement agreement um if
there's a finding of misconduct whatever
the board orders are those are all on
our website and those are also if you
look up a lensey they are also posted
there so if you have a new doctor and
you want to look them up you can look up
their license make sure they're actively
licensed and see if there's any
discipline attached to their record um
I'm not certain if that's answering your
question I'm not sure I'm asking it
exactly to get the information I wanted
because maybe the 20 things that were
reported in Mass assachusetts
hadn't been settled or were settled out
of court or whatever they were it wasn't
up to the standard of what the Board of
Medicine was allowed to do could do or
whatever
counselor good afternoon Douglas
HC um I would say that a majority of the
changes that we saw in 655 and 409
updated the process not so much the
information we're allowed to
share Mr J representative
I I think I can maybe help out um is is
it not true that we had a number of
meetings where we tried in various fora
to
describe what things must be posted and
to date we haven't actually reached a
consensus about what things must be
posted so that the the actual postings
are
not that different from what they were
before what is different from what there
were before is a more robust
investigative process I would say that's
accurate thank you is this is for
anybody is is the process of coming to
arguably better postings are still a
work in
progress well can I ask a question when
you say that there were settlements and
you you kind of referred to court
settlements I mean those will never be
posted on our website if it's a court
settlement um if we receive such a
document and it's considered a complaint
we're not going to post that because
it's confidential um the courts you know
I it's difficult to find out you know I
mean I moved here from another state I
used to look up and do a civil case
search to see any of my new doctors you
know do they have any medical
malpractice cases that were filed
against them and I could see all the
pleadings online and I found that New
Hampshire has chosen not to do that
which I'm not making a judgment call but
that's that's not something you can just
do um but CA case filings would be
something the court would have to post
we would not post those followup
representative Weber and this is just a
statement um my my recollection is that
we had a number of discussions I think
in the context of a bill and uh the
issue that we wrestled with that I think
everybody wrestles with is where is the
line
between uh information that is
clear that needs to be shared with the
public and how early in the process do
we make things public in order to be
fair not only to the Public's right to
know about their providers but also
whether the complaint is about the color
of the jello rather than which may be a
valid complaint but it's not um
actionable in terms of somebody's
practice um and my recollection was that
we wrestled Mally and
didn't have a lot of success in deciding
where that dividing line ought to be so
I think probably the legislature needs
to take some uh ownership for the fact
that until they do successfully grapple
with that issue and set a very clear
standard for what's going to get posted
what's going to get posted isn't going
to change unless it somehow gets changed
by rule but I don't think we've
delegated that Authority so it can't be
changed by rule so until we do something
I don't think anything's going to happen
if that's a help with the process if not
the answer well I think it is because
the answer seems to me that the
difference between what the
Massachusetts Board of Medicine felt
comfortable in posting versus the New
Hampshire leaving any legal terms out of
it whatever they did we didn't and that
isn't changing
yet
okay that's very helpful and and thank
you representative representative Murphy
thank you uh just a follow up to that
conversation so is it fair to say on
your flow diagram here
that uh if a complaint were to result in
any sort of um reprimand that would not
be released to the public until it got
to an Roi into the Board of Medicine it
would not come out publicly before that
is that
correct so if a complaint comes in to
the board of to the oplc and you've gone
through your entire process of
reviewing um an investigator is assigned
to it etc etc and judge or Roi is
determined or is given it would seem to
me then that part would not be public is
that correct that would not be publicly
available in in most other states as
well as ours but it could be at the
point when it gets to the Board of
Medicine it's accurate that the ROI it's
not public at that point because the
board hasn't made a decision so yeah but
it's when the Board of Medicine gets it
and they make a decision to dismiss or
ad adjudicate that's when it would be
potentially out on the public domain is
that correct right if they order
adjudication the notice of the hearing
and the hearing would be public if it's
dismiss missed then there's no notice to
the public that a complaint had been
ping so nothing up to that point in time
of the RO I guess I'm asking is nothing
up to the point of the ROI is really
available to the public correct okay
good thank
you it would be just to beat it to death
it would be the
legislature that will
inform
oplc or the the boards that's one
question where the line should
be you aren't going to do
that they can't change
it that's what I'm trying to pound
several Nails into correct right now we
are unable to disclose that information
okay right it would have to I believe
have to be a statutory change to allow
that Mr chair yes if I could I I think
this transcends the Board of Medicine I
think going to do it for one Healthcare
discipline we have to be doing it for
all not just for one and single someone
else
sure anyone
else thank you attorney Ood and Miz or
Council or what dror
um um I'm buying time until I keep
rehearsing it's a don't worry about it
an I mean I am an attorney but Miz is
fine as well councelor k
polius perfect got it thank you for
coming one more update last legislative
season the Board of Medicine uh with the
mrsc going away was given statutory
authority to create a subcommittee and
they can create um essentially a panel
of experts to Aid our investigators
during investigations uh that's
currently in the rulemaking process
there's drafts I don't have anything yet
to share but the Board of Medicine is
working on those uh so in the future
this extra panel to insist our
investigators will
exist good thank
you next item the developmental Services
redesign implementation status update
pinch hitting for Melissa Hardy
is
Mr I understand
I understand
that good good afternoon Chris Antonello
I'm here for Melissa Hardy today um
so I actually probably have a relatively
um brief update um I know that Melissa
typically this was regarding retain
608 which is now interim study um 608
correct recomend recommended thank you
the house has to vote okay so that's
kind of um where we are um we
um uh November 3rd we presented to the
subcommittee on HB um 608 so some of
this information may be repetitive I
know Melissa spends a lot of time here
talking about stakeholder engagement and
I think that's where I'd like to spend
our time today if that's okay um when we
met in front of the subcommittee to hear
um retain 608 um I shared and I
reiterate today um that the department
is committed to collaborating with all
stakeholders um to improve our
developmental Services System I think
there um has been a lot of anxiety um in
the system because we had a number of
items that we had to move forward for
compliance and now we're past that pit
phase and so we really have the ability
um to stop pause and get meaningful
engagement from all stakeholders whether
that's an individual a family provider
agencies area agencies whomever and so
we've actually started to um map out
some of those stakeholder engagement
sessions
and starting in I think it's after
Thanksgiving we're going to kick off a
number of four um family and information
um
settings um just to really talk and
understand what's working well what's
not working what do you want to see
changed and begin to go down that
process so that's really kind of um
where we are right now and then we will
also be meeting with the area agencies
through CSN I asked some of the same um
issues and then also with our private
provider networks and we're spending the
time really um we don't have any firm
start dates for any new um changes to
the service delivery system we've put
some of the um rate work on hold not the
hb2 rate work that's still happening
January 1st but some of the other rate
work we're putting that on pause a
little bit so
any
questions from
the
committee Mr chair
yes thank thank you Mr chair also thank
you for the update one of the things I
also they talked about was the process
which I'm glad to hear that we're
bringing back the stakeholder
involvement yeah to this degree I think
it's helpful for both both sides of the
fence was the cash flow issue was trying
to find a way to be sure that there's
staying financially viable and a lot of
that comes down to is trying to be sure
that they're getting sufficient cash
because of the the issues around the
billing issue and so forth can you speak
to where we are with that part of it
because sure it's nice to have a process
but you don't have agencies to do the
process we don't have to worry about to
yep totally agree so we actually um have
been meeting with area agencies
oneon-one um because I really think that
you know yes we do a lots of training
and information and meet with a group
but meeting with a agencies oneon-one to
really understand what's your pain Point
what do you need help with and so we've
had um at
least four five four of those with
individ five individual meetings one was
around service authorization the rest
was around cash flow so we're continuing
to work with them and if we have to give
manual payments we've been continuing to
do that we have I know when we were at
the um subcommittee on the 3 we talked
about slowing down like that December
payback and we've absolutely done that
really on an individual basis really
it's up to the agencies but we meet with
them upon request
immediately thank you you're welcome
representative
Weber and I'll just note for having had
a uh conversation with somebody from an
agency fairly recently um there is still
considerable anxiety out there about the
payback issue so that that needs to be
communicated more more Yep clearly I if
um I totally agree not necessarily to me
and the other piece that uh is causing a
great deal of heartburn other than the
how do we enter things properly into the
system so that we can actually get
reimbursed and the mess that that was um
which is slowly I think being
unraveled is is the issue of um direct
entry for the services and and the whole
issue of how do we do it when the cell
phones don't work and that kind of thing
correct y so ongoing ongoing angst is
out there but I know everybody's aware
of it and we're actually really I think
um at a point and working together on
okay what's the issue how do we resolve
it how do we work together what what are
our next
steps okay thank you I just want to make
sure people hear it as often as possible
we hear it thank you and I appreciate
you bringing that forward any other
questions for the associate
commissioner saying none thank you for
your report thank
you next up report on
Veterans access to health care and
Mental Health Services
and we
welcome Wendy
Alman and Heather
Smith and the streak continues of the
ability to turn the mic on at the
beginning without coaching well
done getting the hang of it um for the
record um I'm Wendy Alman I'm the bureau
chief for the Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services
good afternoon I'm Heather Smith and I
work at the department of military
Affairs and veteran services division of
community-based military programs as
their grants and resource development
coordinator thank
you so uh today uh we're here in front
of the committee to be able to um offer
um some highlights and and information
related to uh Senate Bill 174 which is
relative to Veterans access to health
care and Mental Health Services um we've
provided a report uh based on the
legislation that was passed um this past
year and uh both Heather and myself as
partners are prepared to be able to just
provide some of those highlights um and
and uh talk about some of those
initiatives and then offer the
opportunity to answer any questions that
the committee may have um first I'd like
to just uh review what we've provided in
the report um again we've listed out
many of the uh initiatives that include
collaborations and Partnerships between
the Department of Health and Human
Services and the division of military
area Affairs and veteran
services and in addition to this report
we are providing a
um a snapshot um from
2023 that was released that provides an
overview of New Hampshire veterans um in
the state which covers some demographic
and economic information as well as some
programmatic information
highlighting how we are supporting New
Hampshire veterans in our and uh how we
partner um in different ways and so
we're um happy to answer any questions
relative to that um as part of the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh role we continue to have um dedicated
staff within our community mental health
centers um contracts um that focus on
Military
um uh Services um and help uh those who
go to the Community Mental Health
Centers with supports and have that
subject matter expertise we also partner
very closely on training and Outreach
and and as it relates to military
culture we've just had some recent
meetings about scheduling out some of
those trainings that we will offer
Statewide to all of our Human Services
Partners we also work very closely with
our aging and disability Resource
Centers um also known as service link uh
we partner with both of the uh V uh the
white Rover Junction VA and the
Manchester VA to ensure uh supports and
Options Counseling for veterans who want
to receive and direct their own care in
the community um which are services that
are funded through the V with uh service
connected veterans and we provide uh
warm handoffs or you know close
Partnerships with the office of veteran
services in terms of helping individuals
who may need help with long-term
supports and services and navigating um
supports in the community but also need
help with uh questions related to VA
benefits or navigating care support uh
Mental Health Services and making
referrals to the veteran services office
so I'll turn it over to Heather so that
she has a little bit of time to
highlight things from um her division's
perspective thank you um councilman
Pearson our chairman Pearson and all the
honorable committee members for allowing
us to testify to
as to Senate Bill
174 um we're happy to share all the
initiatives that the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
and the Department of Health and Human
Services are in collaboration with and
in tandem working towards helping
veterans access healthc care and
Behavioral Health
Services um so I'd like to highlight
some of those initiatives um
at this um our department the department
military Affairs and veteran services uh
we support and participate in uh various
State councils and committees and
meetings to support families and
Veterans and their families in this
state and that includes the New
Hampshire State military leadership team
and the state veterans advisory
committee
and so I wanted to give you a little bit
of background as far as some the the New
Hampshire military leadership team is
was the beginning Genesis for our
initiative of the New Hampshire veteran
family business Network and that veteran
Finley business
Network um
is started with that M military
leadership team and the state veterans
advisory committee coming together with
our partner in new New Hampshire
employment
security and we partnered with area
businesses such as nextstep bionics and
Prosthetics Dead River Company
hypertherm New Hampshire Hospital
Association Northeast passage UNH
Southern New Hampshire University and an
esgr which is employer support for the G
and
reserves um and so now this network is
in its fourth year and it is still
growing uh we have 60 plus
businesses and we had a recent Symposium
in which 40 of the uh businesses
participated in addition uh the military
leadership team in the state veterans
advisory committee uh
is providing sh shaping guidance for
reinvigorating the New Hampshire ask the
question campaign uh which if you're not
you're all most likely familiar with um
is whereby a clinician care provider law
enforcement teacher asks if one has
asked if a family member or uh yourself
has served in the military and so that
enables a provider to address the next
level of care and a more targeted
approach to Veterans
healthare uh and then another initiative
that the military leadership team and
esac is assessing is addressing the Gap
in uh Dental Health Care needs for our
veterans
um we are modeling our approach after
the state of Maine the state of Maine
and uh worked in coordination with
northe de to
dental uh to provide coverage for
veterans that are cannot pay out a
pocket or or do not have access to
dental
insurance so in addition uh there are
available services for veterans in
isolated pockets of New Hampshire such
as in North Country that will provide on
a regional level
assistance um we we do not have a
Statewide program for that so we're
currently uh looking into um looking
into this through uh and
assessing um the capacity and resources
that are
available to meet these needs at this
time um in addition uh I'd like to
highlight some of our um the Outreach
that our veteran service officers a
division of veteran
services um as you see on our uh page
here we have over 94,000 veterans in the
state of New
Hampshire only only
approximately I would say
40% are enrolled in VA Health Care
System but so we have a small office of
veteran service officers that work with
these clients bringing in approximately
$65 million
each year of federal
funds into the grant state to assist
these
veterans uh the veteran service officers
case load they have approximately 4,000
contacts we have voice and email this
Rose during the pack act period up to
6,000 um a month and now that that pack
pack act en period has passed we're now
back down to approximately 4,000 a month
and right now we are currently booking
appointments for services into December
and
January uh we also work in partnership
with
DHHS um the New Hampshire National Guard
the New Hampshire Suicide Prevention
Council and other state departments and
Community providers to prevent suicide
of amongst
veterans uh we also participate in the
suicide prevention Council military and
Veteran
committee um through these recent
efforts we are able to work with
DHHS along to highlight the governor's
suicide prevention week uh you saw the
impact of that in the recent uh press
releases as well as the granite strong
campaign strong as
Granite I do want to let you know that
the New Hampshire I mean the US I
apologize the US Department of Veterans
Affairs released data yesterday in
regards to New Hampshire veteran suicide
uh this rate has dropped um it was 36%
in 2020 and is now 29 3% in
2021 uh why we recognize that this is
great news that the rate has dropped we
still recognize that the veteran suicide
rate is still higher than the national
suicide rate average and the state of
New Hampshire
average uh let's see we also uh like to
highlight there's some uh available uh
suicide prevention
training um the New Hampshire through
the New Hampshire National Guard there's
a assist applied suicide intervention
skills training it's a two-day
training and Nami New Hampshire uh
designed and teaches the connect online
training um it is a three moduled
self-paced and can be taken
online um in addition to that uh Nami
New Hampshire worked with Harbor care to
provide train the trainer training for
suicide prevention and through those
efforts we're now able to continue
Outreach to the VFW leadership uh we're
they're collaborating uh with the VFW
leadership so that the VFW Post would
have a point of contact if somebody had
Su suicidal
iations so reaching out to those
communities on a broader effort
in addition uh the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
has contracted has Contracting efforts
with Easter sees New Hampshire uh to
provide uh to have
enhanced uh capacity for mental health
services and to New Hampshire service
veteran service members veterans and the
families uh as well as a uh Contracting
efforts with the partnership for public
health to create
coalitions to address Su veteran suicide
and social
isolation uh we're I'm going to ask you
to kind of bring this to a conclusion
I'm following along this and I intend on
reading it at home but perhaps uh the
committee would wish to ask some
questions oh I certainly I apologize no
no problem yeah representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the
question the intent of the bill was to
look
at healthc Care Mental Health Access by
the veterans in your opinion in writing
this
report would you say it's a lack of
awareness um is it a question about
availability of Workforce is it a
question about locality in other words
in the state of Hampshire we have one VA
facility in Manchester we have another
one in the border with Vermont way re
Junction is a question of a
awareness we don't have enough people to
provide service to the veterans or they
just don't have time or the ability to
get to the sites where they can get the
service so just to understand your
question um you wish to know if there is
a lack of capacity to is it a lack of
the veterans being aware of what's going
on what's available to them is it a
question of lack of capacity which is
really driven by the workforce or is it
a a lack of um access in a sense of
geographically if I live in Burlington
bermont sorry Burlington New Hampshire
and I have to go all the way down to
Manchester it becomes a difficult
Journey for me to get down
there um in terms of the the needs um
part of the snapshot that was provided
in the packet really does um outline a
couple of the needs that we focus on um
one of those is the coordinated um
referral and assistance which really is
you need we need to make sure that uh
veteran service members and their
families have increased awareness so you
know that definitely is part of the
initiatives and efforts it's weaved in
everywhere um um the other is uh
increasing the capacity for community-
Based Services um and having that
Equitable across all regions um so
that's certainly something that we're
looking at when we do uh our listening
sessions or gaps analysis in terms of uh
what may be available to individuals and
uh veterans uh military service members
and their families are are part of that
uh population that we're working with um
and certainly with the with the veteran
service officers the goal primarily is
to make sure PE more people have
increased access to the to the VA
enrollment and what that process looks
like and being able to support them
through that thank you representative
Weber this is mostly going to be
observations and some of it's a plea if
if I were a veteran I wouldn't know
whether I needed to go because I in
Chester County to the Keen Veteran
Center to the White River Junction VA
Center to the Manchester VA Center or
would I call the community behavioral
health center or would I contact Nami or
would I try and get through to 211 which
is sometimes not as helpful as it might
be and so I'm going to do the thing that
I've done in the context of any number
of other agencies and say I have 20
years of formal education and a law
degree and I'm a
representative and I have access to a
lot of people to explain things to me
and I have a good computer and I can't
figure this out so if I don't have good
access to Computer Services and people
who can help explain it to me uh what
I've heard today is who is liazon with
who and partnering with who and making
uh a a web with who
and I wind up with an image in my mind
of a giant spider web where everybody's
talking to everybody else about who's
talking to whom and I'm still not clear
who's providing the services or where
and um I know that in the context of
Mental Health Access for the general
population we talk about no wrong door
and we talk about getting people to the
services they need but dear God could we
have fewer
doors and you
know a simpler and more direct line to
Services overall I know that's not
something you're going to do by next
Friday but it's a plea that I make
because um I sometimes try and explain
to constituents where they find services
and when it's hard for me and I've been
serving on Health and Human Services for
six or eight years now if I can't find
where they should
go then how are they going to find it I
mean I I always do but that's usually
because I call our Mr Williams and he
points me in the right direction and not
everybody can do that he can't do that
for everybody in the State uh so I I
just I'm really concerned about the
number of different
little the number of different
organizations that each have a little
tiny piece of the
pie uh but I'm afraid that there are an
awful lot of veterans who are getting no
pie so I I just throw that out there
because it's a real concern to me and
I'm sure it's a real concern to you as
well CU I know that you're I know that
you're working hard on it but it's it's
not
easy thank you chair has a question
speaking of uh Mr Williams He regularly
appes us with a document called
DHHS contact list for constituent
referrals and I'm looking down on page
two to um elderly long-term supports and
services indent elderly and Adult
Services skip a line when the ultimate
administrator but the line I skip talks
about community service is nursing home
and residential care I don't see
veterans on there should
I we wouldn't necessarily specifically
identify a one population we serve all
populations all pairs so um in terms of
whether or not somebody's served in the
military or they have family who served
in the military that's something that we
would ask um based on them you know
contacting us and providing you know a
warm handoff to um an organization or
one of our um one of our program staff
within the bureau if they had a specific
question or need um that may relate to
their connection um to being a veteran
or a service member allow me to
disagree the line item speaks
specifically of nursing homes and then
we get down a little bit further and we
talk about seniors with mental health
needs I'm reading this do doent and I'm
seeing some nice
breakouts this doesn't help me in terms
of what representative Weber isn't
feeling helped with this needs this
document I appreciate it it's better
than none when I was growing up I never
had anything like this this is wonderful
it's not enough if you want to make it
four
pages fine but I want to be able to see
under the subheadings and the sub
subheadings
a lot more breakouts as to whom I
call and not just on your line item
which I don't think you probably wrote I
think somebody wrote it for
you and some of the others this is a
good start it's not enough that's my
plea thank you and I'll pass that on to
John Williams he's on vacation in North
Carolina visiting he told me Mayberry
and Andy and goober and Gomer and and
Barney 5 he said that actually in
uh but when he gets back yes this would
be very helpful in the next addition
thank you anyone
else chairman yes uh representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman let's
hope Andy doesn't arrest Mr Williams
while he's down that be Barney anyway
but um I'd always heard and and I don't
think it's in here and I don't think
you've addressed it New Hampshire has if
not the highest per capita population of
veterans we have one of the highest is
that
true
I believe we are in the top 10 sir okay
top 10 okay so we're not the're not the
most per capita than I because I had
heard that I I'm but it's a fairly heavy
per capita veterans population from what
I can see is that fair to say
or are you looking I know it's not
broken out like that I'm just thinking
that that that contributes to the
problem that it's it's it's that heavy
so anyway thank you
anyone else any other
questions thank you so much for coming
you thank
you
and Report update regarding the use of
restraints and the use of different
modes of transportation of patients to
New Hampshire hospital or designated
receiving facilities and this is a
particular interest to mine because my
other son not the one that's in the
legislature he's on team red he's a fire
Lieutenant but my younger son Michael
who's team blue who's a corrections
officer at a Maximum Security Prison in
New York and he transports patients back
and forth all the time so we've had long
Chats on this so this is going to be
fascinating to
me I'll try to show restraints and my
enthusiasm just for clarification when
we talk talked about team red and team
blue was that fire and police yes thank
you welcome they have a hockey game
every
year well good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you for
having me my name is Caroline Lavoy I'm
the senior director of health
information and analytics at the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
analy and I am Cynthia bonis and I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
hospital executive
team and I'm going to walk you through
the fourth iteration of this report but
before I do so I do want to give just a
little bit of background on why we are
collecting and Reporting on this data to
you so all patients designated as an
involuntary emergency admission or iea
in New Hampshire must be transported
from the emergency department from which
they were admitted to New Hampshire
hospital or another one of the six
designated receiving facilities or drfs
to receive the appropriate inpatient
psychiatric treatment historically those
transports were all done by law
enforcement but Senate Bill 177
effective January 1st of 2020 allowed
for the explicit option to use an
ambulance for the transport along with
law enforcement and the idea was to
reduced the number of restraints and
Associated trauma um but still
protecting everyone involved the patient
the employees and the general public so
now a provider who declares the Ia
chooses the appropriate mode of
transportation for the patient and the
transport agency themselves decides if
restraints are appropriate in the
situation um in addition to these change
in protocol uh the law also mandated
that all the drfs report annually to
this committee uh on the number of
restraints broken down by age type of
transport and restraint usage New
Hampshire Hospital Association
volunteered on behalf of its members to
consolidate this and um bring it to the
committee uh in a consistent
manner so this is now the fourth report
that uh is brought to the committee and
it's covering the months of October 2022
to September of
2023 if we turn to the report itself so
the top of page one just has a little
bit more background on Senate Bill
177 and the bottom of page one there's
some summary statistics for you so there
were
1,146 IA transfers in this year that's
an average of 96 per month 99% of those
transports were adults um in time in
terms of type of transport we have 38%
by ambulance 61% by law enforcement and
1% by other means and other means could
be facility St family members that type
of thing just over half of all
transports did use restraints uh to move
the patient and in terms of type of
restraints used I have the breakdown
there just about half were a combination
and then there are others um handcuffs
was spt only leg restraint
only top of page two uh have a table
here just shows you the breakdown of
number of transports by drf to give you
a sense the volume um each drf brings
in and then the following sections are
summaries of the different data points
if you want to see more detail there is
an appendix in the back with uh some
tables for you so let's look at adults
first we have the mode of transportation
um about 61% of adults went by law
enforcement 38% by ambulance and you can
see by the chart that this stayed
relatively consistent over the 12
months the next page we're looking at
restraint
application um for law enforcement it's
about 86% of all adults transported by
law enforcement had restraints applied
for ambulance there were only two
instances in the 12 months in which
restraints were applied so you can see
there's a very uh stark contrast between
the two transport options in terms of
restraint usage and then the following
page we see just a breakdown of the type
of restraints used by law enforcement um
no one is really dominant over the
others for the CH child transports there
were only eight children transported as
an iea in the 12-month period five by
ambulance and three by law enforcement
and restraint usage was divided directly
by the type of transport
ambulance using
none then the next two pages since this
is now the fourth iteration of the
report gives you some trending data and
to summarize the trends and other than a
reduction in the average number of
transports per month and the precipitous
drop of children because of change in
protocol things are remaining relatively
stable across the years in terms of the
type typ of um transport and how they're
using restraints so we're seeing that
the medical community is pretty
consistent in their choices when it
comes to iea
transports and that's the summary for
the year for report and open up for
questions any questions yes
representative
Weber thank you for the report and thank
you for taking my
question um so I'm delighted by the low
number of transport of children but I
want to know how the kids are getting
from one place to another are they just
being taken by their parents in most
cases is that what
happens the majority of children's
admissions are voluntary they're not IA
and so it would be a parent
transport
okay in that case I'm kind of wondering
if I've got a disconnect here somewhere
because we hear about kids waiting in
Waiting rooms in emergency
rooms and they're waiting for a
voluntary placement rather than an
involuntary placement is that what's
happening for children waiting in
emergency
rooms because children are minors their
parents can admit them voluntary by
Guardian to a facility so yes they are
waiting in an emergency room for a
voluntary by Guardian I gotcha okay that
that was the disconnect thank you very
much
seeing no questions thank you so
much a l addition to
the agenda representative Leah kushman
has asked if she could make a brief
presentation to us when I got the gist
of it I felt this was in keeping with
what this committee does we receive
reports from DHHS but we also exercise
some
oversight
and her request seemed Germaine to
me thank you chairman
Pearson thank you fellow members of the
house did you hold off until we have the
paperwork we're trying to figure out
what is a I see stack yeah they're all
just I figured it out okay vertical
versus horizontal I think I know
that pre yes wow see we're not used to
being spoiled like that well sometimes
we are okay I know how fun it is to try
to do that in the seat while someone's
talking
so
very good
so um good morning for the record my
name is Leah kushman um I'm an agent of
the people serving in the general court
representing you be closer to the
microphone please bring it closer to me
um Mr chairman I thank you for getting
this matter before the committee um
without delay I didn't have as much time
to gather um stories and names of people
who have dealt with the dayc carees in
this issue specifically um but it's not
as important as the Constitution and
legal principles around um why this is
an issue um it's all Focus there so
after the LA uh over the last couple of
years I've received numerous complaints
about child care agencies denying
exemptions to vaccination I had heard
many stories and um directed people to
the statute and said you know show this
to them and um they should honor your
exemption then I received an email from
a woman who sent me a screenshot and it
was of an email from the child care
licensing unit which is under under the
Department of Health and Human Services
to a child care agency um which you have
there is the first page in the handouts
and I believe what the uh cclu agent
stated and that email is incorrect and
they're not enforcing the law and even
worse they're actively colluding with a
licy to deny rights to the people under
the law which is Mal Administration and
now that they've received notice of this
they continue it meiz to the level of
malice um first I want to establish what
rights are they're inalienable you'd
have them even if the government didn't
exist um and they would only be taken
from you by force government exists only
to protect you from having your rights
unduly taken from others by force I've
printed out for you some handouts if you
look at the one with the Constitutional
articles on it um I believe it's at the
end of the first page or top of the SEC
second of those uh article 38 a frequent
frequent
recurrence um to the fundamental
principles of the Constitution the
people have a right to require of their
lawgivers and magistrates an exact and
constant observance of them in the
formation and execution of the
laws um that's why I'm walking us
through the Constitution here um because
it says that we frequently need to
revert back to it and refer to it and
look at it so part one um article one
says all men are born equally free and
independent therefore all government of
right originates from the people is
founded in consent and instituted for
the general good article 3 says when men
enter into a state of society they
surrender up some of their natural
rights to that Society in order to
ensure the protection of others and
without such an equivalent the surrender
is void so government exists with the
people's consent and they I just ask a
point of order you may ask a point of
order
always these are con thank you and thank
you for taking my inquiry it would be
very helpful if I understood before you
start reading the applicable
constitutional principles if I
understand what the problem is because
I've heard the principles many many
times and I don't know in what context
you're addressing them except that it
has something to do with child care
licensing so if you could tell me what
the actual problem that people are
encountering is first and then explain
the constitutional principles it would
be really very helpful to me thank you
um as I said a lot of people are being
denied enrollment for child care because
as they um are seeking to use their
right to religious exemption um for
vaccination requirements so um
government exists with the people's
concent again before you do this we want
to nail this down some Child Care
Facilities yes private businesses have
are taking what they believe is their
right to refuse to admit a child into
their business into their group of kids
uh because somebody is not immunized
correct and your assertion is a private
business does not have that right um not
according to our well okay I I want to
get the
point point is that
it that's the main gist of it yes okay
any anyone want to continue to yes
representative Merchant let be clear are
we're talking about private business not
a public entity can I finish my what I'm
trying to because once I read this to
you you'll understand where I'm going it
depends if you're going to go through a
whole long recitation of the
Constitution no you may not I'm not
going through a whole I'm going to go
Point by point with the law and how
they're violating it okay is everybody
clear what the allegation is here that
we're we're trying to deal with yes and
no I'm I'm clear about the allegation
I'm not clear why a private private
business is required to
um why a private business is not allowed
to govern their own business
practices M please I we're talking
about private child care not Public
Child Care are we talking about
both uh New Hampshire law says a all
child care agencies that are licensed
and the licensing rules also say that
they have to honor the exemptions
so public or private so the private or
public isn't really at issue because
they're all licensed so therefore
they're all under a public control I
think we're asserting I think we're
asserting that okay please continue
thank you um so we're here to protect
people's rights and um that's what
legislators were doing when they created
RSA 141 C 20-a and see those are um on
that in that stapled packet there they
imposed a requirement for the protection
of rights of the whole but acknowledged
and took due care to protect the
inalienable rights of the minority at
the same time um that statute says no
child shall be enrolled without the
required vaccinations partial
vaccination or exemption then it refers
to 141 c20c where exemptions for medical
issues or religious beliefs are to be
accepted in Le of vaccination so they
created law that balance the rights of
different people where they may conflict
that's a problem Rule now the next
statute RSA 170e talks about licenses
being required for certain child care
agencies um and they'll be issued in the
form and matter as prescribed by the
rules then you go to the rules further
down and you see HC
4210 D where it repeats the statute that
the agency or leny shall request
documentation on immunizations in
accordance with RSA 141
c2a and then in F that exemptions to
immunization shall be in accordance with
RSA 141 c 20- c the legislature put a
requirement on schools and daycares that
children who are enrolled shall be
either vaccinated per statute or provide
an exemption from the email from Melissa
Clement the unit chief for the child
care licensing unit she stated according
to DHHS legal council and you have a
copy of that there the public
accommodation statute States it's
unlawful for anyone including a private
business to refuse withhold or deny any
person accommodations ADV vages
facilities or privileges because of age
sex race Creed color marital status
physical or mental disability or
national origin she goes on to say
vaccination status is not a protected
class under this law that is a
deflection and is what I like to call a
lawyer trick that controvers the
controversy at hand is not whether
someone has a protection protection for
vaccination status it's whether they
have a protection from discrimination
for religious beliefs or disability as
is afforded to them in the form of the
right to exemptions it says Creed right
there in the statute um that she
referenced the constitution of New
Hampshire says Creed in part one Article
2 that's on your handout today Creed has
a more narrow meaning of official
statement of faith of a religious
institution but um in the time of the
Constitution's writing uh the definition
was more broad Noah Webster 1828 says
it's that which is believed any system
of principles which are believed or
professed as a political Creed uh Creed
is protected in our constitution freedom
from religious discrimination is also
required uh by the federal Civil Rights
Act of 1964 in places of public
accommodation disability is also
protected um so a medical exemption
would fall under that under the
Americans with Disabilities Act these
are protected rights per the
Constitution and federal and state law
Mr chairman we hear a lot of talk about
the rights of private businesses if a
business is incorporated it deres its
very existence from the legislature it
was created through statute the
legislature created the statutes that
enable the creation of incorporate
Incorporated entities such as es Corps
llc's 501
c3s can the legislature Grant Authority
in statute to violate inalienable rights
reserved back to the people no it
doesn't have that Authority the
legislature has no authority to violate
those rights or delegate a violation of
rights to to another entity maximum loss
as the derivative power cannot be
greater than the original from which
it's derived Miranda versus Arizona
where rights secured by the Constitution
are involved they're can be no Ru making
or legislation which would abgate them
this is also true of lenses lur is a
creation of the legislature I believe
the legislature understood that in
creating RSA 141c that while they could
impose requirements for schools and
daycares concerning vaccinations they
also had to ensure they were not
granting Authority for government or
it's created entities to violate
Constitution and federal law balance
it's about balancing protected rights so
um all government agencies and agents
are bound to the highest law and
expected to act act on behalf of the
people and defend their rights so we've
got the law creating balance of Rights
in mind we have an agency created for
common good of the people and entrusted
to protect those rights we have a leny
who agreed to play by the rules for a
lure and if they're Incorporated they
agreed to play by those rules in
exchange for the sovereignty um to give
up some sovereignty in exchange for the
corporate Shield so the laws and
approval laws and rules apply to these
entities they don't apply to each child
once they're enrolled only they apply to
the agency as a whole and how it
conducts its business so we have the
exemption in the law um and I I just see
a big problem with the agency and agents
and the attorneys all paid by the people
and granted their Authority by the
people working together with the
childcare licensing unit against the
constitutional rights of the people um
so on on your handout part one article 8
it says all power residing originally in
and derive from from the people all
magistrates and officers of government
are their substitutes and agents and all
times accountable to them article 14
says every subject of the state is
entitled to a certain remedy um and it
goes on to say that it should be
complete and without denial and it
should be promptly without delay and
conformable to the laws so I'm just
asking that we remedy this issue um here
and now without delay restore the rights
to the people as guaranteed to them in
the Constitution and the federal and
state laws um I I guess we just need the
commissioner to to um give us a plan for
that to be implemented that this
practice of uh telling people that they
don't have that
right uh representative uh kushman in
the letter that starts good afternoon
representative kushman in the signed by
Melissa
Clement um towards the end of the big
paragraph in the middle people are not
to be denied by age sex race Creed the
word creed comes to Latin kredo
I believe it is used in the beginning of
the nyine crade and the apostles crade
it is a religious statement broader than
but it at least is that so
therefore if I'm reading this correctly
one's Creed is not a a legitimate reason
to deny and then if I go over to 141
c20c in the next handout apparent legal
guardian a child should be exempt from
immunization if the parent or legal
guardian signs a form because of
religious beliefs now that means the
child can be exempt from having to have
a vaccine um I'm not sure where daycare
centers fit in under that exemption at
the bottom of the page so I'm arguing
both sides of this year I'm just trying
to get stuff into evidence
representative
Weber well that leads me to my comment
which is we don't take evidence here I
mean we listen to people but we are not
an adjudicatory body and the remedy for
a violation of the public accommodation
statute or any of those other things
lies not with us but with either the
Human Rights Commission or the
courts respectfully I disagree how would
that provide prompt and without delay uh
remedy for rights violated we absolutely
work with the Departments all the time
and advise them on practices that may
not be correct and this seems like the
perfectly appropriate body to have that
discussion with the Department say hey
this is this practice is out of line
with the Constitution and our laws and
we would like you to change them
representative Weber because what is the
problem here is one person has the
rights that you're talking about but if
I have a child that I want to send to
daycare and I don't want them to be
exposed to things that I don't want them
to be exposed to you are B there are two
sets of people with two sets of Rights
all all of which are
important and The Balancing Act there is
either for
certainly the legislature is a part of
it but if you feel that the existing
laws are not being enforced
correctly that is why we have a
Judiciary it's to balance the rights of
various parties all of whom have
rights as opposed to accepting the
rights of one set of people as absolute
and the rights of other people as lesser
than respectfully the right to Religious
Freedom is in our Constitution and it's
in our laws
so to be argued but the other right that
you mentioned is not a constitutional
right fine I understand the the balance
here excuse the question is is this the
venue to solve this
problem I think if the department is
willing to listen
and take heed of the notice that they've
received that they're out of compliance
with the law and they're failing to
uphold the law then yes I think this is
a perfectly fine
venue I believe it's a venue to listen
and that's why I granted you to come
today I don't think we have the
authority to enforce anything and tell
them what they have to
do um other members of the committee how
do you read our
charge I've explained my position okay I
leave representative Murphy well thank
you I I I I understand that the um the
concern um and I would agree that if a
child or any individual is um uh
jeopardized um acceptance into a
business or child care or any other
organization based on their religion
that's a problem that should be a
problem and it is a problem in the
Constitution as you pointed out
however um to me if the parents have
chosen not to have a vaccination given
to the child because of religious
beliefs that's entirely their
prerogative I would think so my question
is I would agree I I don't believe that
we're the correct body to look at this
it seems to me that this is basically um
a question for the courts to decide um
only because it is in statute that they
cannot be discriminated against because
of age sex Creed you know Etc but not
necessarily vaccination I I you know and
again regardless of private versus
public um there there are so many other
competing priorities including as
representative Weber said other people's
you know concerns and uh rights it
doesn't seem to me that this is the
correct body to make that distinction it
would seem to me like the courts of law
should be the ones that handle
this anyone else representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman
uh I know what this body was created by
Statute does anybody have a copy of the
statute handy that so that we can know
our charge exactly as it's spelled
out thank you representative Weber
take she's faster than representative
Merchant with the
laptop I'm sorry
here RSA
126a
8113 I know it's on the calendar but I
don't have a calendar with
me you don't have a calendar yeah I mean
I think
calendar
just call me they want to
talk 126 may I read number
three 126 a13
yeah it reads um article three Roman
three says the oversight committee on
Health and Human Services shall provide
legislative oversight of the department
to
support a coste effective comprehensive
coordinated system syst of Health and
Human Services that is family oriented
and communitybased the committee shall
promote greater efficiencies by
consolidating and centralizing Reporting
requirements and other responsibilities
of the department under this section to
avoid duplication of efforts including
other non-regulatory boards commissions
councils advisory committees and task
force that that is the legislative
charge to the committee the
representative has made a case and
before we go
further um does this
group believe that having heard the
charge to this group we should proceed
and if so in what manner that will be
the discussion representative
King I first have to declare that I'm an
engineer and I don't do well in these
areas
is um but if if I
can the way I look at this is that a
charge has been made not that we're here
to make the decision on what needs to
be uh executed or uh determined it's
just
that we could be the committee that
brings it to the
DHHS to be reviewed and and a response
made and matter fact I think I heard
representative kushman make that
reference at one point that she was
looking for a plan or maybe a statement
from the commissioner on what they have
found and if we if that's not
satisfactory then she could take it to
the next level and U and then take it to
a court of law that's what I've heard
but then again I am an engineer
other members representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question representative
kishman I think there's also another
Avenue to explore ABA through the
process there's the issue going to the
courts and trying to resolve the
conflict between rights you could also
as a legislator introduce a bill to
clarify it and maybe that's another
Avenue for one to consider because if I
read through on the RSA
A113 I don't see where the committee
here has enforcement authority over the
department and that's the part I'm
trying to wrestle with I see a lot of
things to do with coordination of care
reports in that part of it but not so
much the compliance or
enforcement within the the RSA itself so
I'm kind of reluctant to go down that
path because of it but however I would
also say as a representative you have
the full Authority as a member of this
legislative body to introduce a bill to
provide
clarification thank you for for that um
there anyone else in the committee I've
shut your mic off anyone else in the
committee want to give an answer to how
we should
proceed I I think I think I've made it
clear but I just want to say that I
don't think this falls into our charge I
think our charge is
far more an administrative and
Reporting thing we certainly don't have
as far as I know the ability to tell the
commissioner that they're going to do
anything I think that the fact that the
representative has brought to us this
concern and it's been heard here uh that
certainly the department will know that
it is a concern but it has also been
brought to them directly and I don't see
what this committee can do consistent
with separation of powers uh to compel
them to do um something that they're not
going to do anyway uh that would be
either changing their mandate by
changing the statute which you have a a
road towards or
a
um resort to either the Human Rights
Commission or the Judiciary as an
Enforcement Act of what's already in
place so uh th those are both I think
more appropriate forums than this one
because I don't think this is within our
charge you may turn your mic back
on thank you Mr chairman there's a whole
section
under RSA
126a colum 15 that has the duties of the
oversight committee and it says it's
include but not limited to
analyzing and it goes down to the the
fourth line reviewing alternate approach
approaches to programmatic and
administrative
concerns um
and so that's where I felt that this was
the appropriate committee um I
appreciate at least being able to air
the concern here in the public um and I
I hope to work with the Department I
don't want to have to bring legislation
we shouldn't have to bring legislation
for what's already in law and people
shouldn't have to go to court to sue for
what they already have a legal right to
either would you give that reference
again because I'm slow to write it down
I want to look at up the charge to this
committee where you believe perhaps we
we could do something about that what's
the um the number
126-a col 15 Roman
one okay
um I I'm I propose yes you may please uh
the I believe that the effective part of
that says the committee shall provide
legislative oversight of and
informational meetings on this is what
you were reading to us the programs
policies and rules of the department as
brought to its attention by committee
members legislators Department Personnel
or others so far so good but the
committee shall monitor the efficiency
of operation and the quality of services
provided the committee's work may
include but is not limited to analyzing
the efficiency of selected programs uh
studying the character istics of Target
populations researching Trends affecting
programs costs and participation and
reviewing alternate approaches to
programmatic and administrative concerns
uh the committee may make
recommendations to the committee
commissioner and recommendations for
legislation um and shall maintain
Communications with the department and
any other departments as necessary I
still don't see that that provides the
focus that you're concerned about as
opposed to a more uh
narrowly
administrative oversight so that's just
me representative McDonald thank you Mr
chairman um I'm new to this committee
I've only been on it this year and I
know that may be true of a number of US
Representative um oh Mr chairman
representative Pearson three years I
know you you've been on it for three is
have we ever got into any kind of
enforcement or of anything of that
nature and the history of the in your
experience or I I've only served two
terms on the committee I had a Hiatus
last I've served years um I haven't I
haven't seen or heard of them and and
certainly in my work on the Health and
Human Services committee the issues that
we have referred to the committee when I
was not sitting on it have been of a
different nature why not this since this
is going to take some thought I would
propose that I send a memorandum to all
of our
members and um if you could email me the
packets because I don't have a scanner
to turn it into emails and I will send
this to them and I will say the question
I would like us to consider as a
committee is is this something we should
go forward with in other words a broad
definition of what we can do versus a
very narrow definition of it and if it
is our conclusion we're not going to
touch this we're not going to touch it
and if it the majority of people think
we should go forward with something at
least maybe just a recommendation
because we have no enforcement we will
work towards that um how does that
strike you all I don't think we can
decide it today would we decide it by
next month is my question representative
Merchant I
would ask the chair to consider reaching
out to house counsel oh sure understand
where we are because at this point in
time I don't know if we have actually
have any legal Authority in this Arena I
think the house council could advise us
on where we're treading so we don't very
wise very wise thank you representative
McDonald sure thank you Mr chairman I
concur I mean there's a legitimate
concern here representative kushman
there's no question about that um but
this committee needs to make sure we're
operating within it within our bounds
and if we don't then we could actually
make it worse if we if we overstep and
undermine our ability to to to even meet
the you know the clear charge specified
in statute so um I I would concur and I
having worked with attorney Cy on other
issues most recently uh subcommittee
that representative Merchant and I were
on he's very good he's very thorough and
I and I think he can give us wise
counsel so how's
that thank you that that would be great
yeah I just even if it just comes down
to a recommendation to the you know that
a legislative uh committee was looking
at it and finds that it's inappropriate
and that they should change their
practices you know I wasn't saying that
you guys you know go to the speaker and
get a warrant and you know subpoena and
yeah oh that crosses my mind on many
occasions so thank you yeah and the
restraints are put on me when I do thank
you so
much um is there anybody from the
Department which wishes to speak to this
issue
yes come on
up you you are
here sorry hi uh for the record Melissa
saier I'm the chief legal officer for
the Department I oversee our legal
services but I also oversee um our light
our Bureau of Licensing and
certification which includes childcare
licensing um the and and I I agree with
um representative kushman that you know
there there may be a a valid reason I
can't speak to um whether or not these
individuals have a a right or a claim
obviously um but I our childcare
licensing rules they oversee the quality
of services with that are provided by
the Child Care Agency they don't oversee
the kind of how they accept children
into their program it really only has to
do with the quality of services that are
provided once they're actually there and
in the program and so we do require them
to have on record if it if if Public
Health requires if our
141c um statute requires that
immunizations be on record that we
require the Child Care Agency to hold
those in their record and if there's an
exemption they also have to have that
exemption in their record for the child
for the child that's in their care but
we don't dictate who they can and cannot
take in because it really only has to do
with um 171e which is our our statute
that talks about quality of Services of
of the children in their charge um that
that being said there is a statute
around um discrimination for um certain
aspects under R say 354a which is what
was mentioned already if there is a
discrimination uh uh any kind of you
know discrimination that has been
alleged at a childcare institution we
would contact Department of Justice for
them to handle that situation so it's
not something that we um would deal with
from a licensing perspective because
like I said that has to do with the
quality of services so it's really the
Department of Justice who uh we would
contact and just say there's been a
claim that that there's discrimination
against this um this family for you know
the way that they're intaking children
and and then we would leave it in their
hands to investigate and and make a
determination or they or the individual
themselves the parent themselves can
also seek their own counsel so that's
essentially how we handle that um so
even if we think about it for a month
and come back and say hey let's let's uh
send a memo to
DHHS it isn't DHHS that would reive
something cancel that meeting um the
complaint would come to you folks yes if
we got a complaint that there was a
discrimination that there was a
violation of that statute that's not our
we only enforce RSA 170e that's all we
have the authority to enforce under
childcare licensing so other statute
including the public health statute we
would have to refer to Public Health if
it were a one 354a discrimination
statute we would have to refer to the
Department of Justice or or as I said
they would have to seat their own
councel could the agreed citizen go to
doj directly uh absolutely okay
absolutely
yep Mr chairman yes just to clarify
which meeting did you want to
cancel uh not next month the the um the
scanning all of these documents and
sending everybody an email and coming to
the conclusion whether we want to uh
make a remonstrance to the commissioner
and that's off the table now because it
doesn't matter even if we did yes
representative Merchant yes I think it's
definitely off the table but if it's
okay with the chair I still like to have
the chair reach out to house counsel to
understand what our role and what our
what our gu rails are because I think if
this comes to us be again or anything
like it we should be able to respond to
it accordingly saying this is not within
our scope um of authorities just get
that cleared get it cleared up and get
it done with because other things like
this will come up so let's be ready yeah
Mr chairman good yes and and for that
purpose would it be appropriate for
representative kushman to still send
that so that house legal council could
look at that paperwork or you have an
extra copy when I run up to see uh legal
council you know where he is right what
sir you know where he is right yeah yeah
yeah fourth floor thank
you any anything else you have for us
that's all I have thank you so much you
have cut the Gordon Gord and notot thank
you thank you yes thank you okay there
we are that's the agenda and I think we
gave a good airing to that subject and
we have a Way Forward Representative
kushman no
happy well I mean not you know crazy
happy but GL thank you that's what I
wanted okay with that next month
December 15th going away party for Paula
Lan so she's already gone away and
practicing going away and that will be
Friday December 15th at 1 p.m. thank you
we are
auring
that